Those who have eyes to see and ears to
hear will then see how Jesus our Lord is
fulfilling the promises, the prophecies,
the pictures, the types found in the Old
Testament. Now, what do I mean by that?
If you go to Genesis chapter 2 and 3,
we're not going to read the entire
chapters. I'm going to summon them up,
but we're going to read some relevant
portions. Genesis 2 and 3 speak about
Adam and Eve. But what's interesting is
Eve is not given the name or Eve until
after her sin and fall and expulsion.
She's called
in Genesis 3:20 after God has already
judged them for their sin. Prior to
that, her name was not Eve. Her name in
Hebrew was I isha.
Isha comes from the Hebrew word ish.
What does that mean? Go to Genesis 2,
brother, if you don't mind, and start
reading 21- 24.
>> All right. Genesis 2 21- 24.
>> Genesis 2 verse 21.
>> So the Lord God caused a deep sleep to
fall upon the man, and he slept. Then he
took one of his ribs and closed up the
flesh at that place. By the way, if you
go look at the Hebrew, the word rib can
also mean sigh. Now, notice
God caused Adam to go into a deep sleep.
Guys, pay attention language because I'm
going to go real in depth. I'm going to
show you the spiritual mean because the
New Testament is not only about
historical events. It's about historical
events that point to greater spiritual
realities. And that's true with the Old
Testament. These historical events and
persons, their lives are meant to point
to greater spiritual realities. And it's
our job by the spirit to then discover
those spiritual realities. So number
one, Adam was put into a deep sleep.
Number two, his side was cut open. If
you read the Hebrew, the word for rib is
also side. His side was cut open. And
from the side, Adam, Adam's wife was
fashioned. And then his side was then
closed up. Keep reading.
>> Okay.
Um, the Lord God fashioned into a woman
the rip which he had taken from the man
and brought her to the man. The man
said, "This is now bone of my bones and
flesh of my flesh. She shall be called
woman because she was taken out of a man
out of man."
>> And then 24 says what? For this reason a
man shall leave his father and his
mother and be joined to his wife and
they shall become one flesh.
>> Now notice he says you are isha because
you came from ish. The English words
woman and man in Hebrew it's you are I
isha because you came from. Adam looks
at Eve and says, "You are bone of my
bones, flesh of my flesh." Because she
was made out of out of Adam's flesh,
made from his bones, and has Adam's
blood in her veins. He says, "Because of
that reason, you're called Isha." Isha
is the word Hebrew word for female,
woman, or wife. Why are you Isha?
Because you came out of ish. The Hebrew
word ish is the word for male, man, or
husband.
In fact, even the English words woman
and man. Woman etmologically means from
the womb of man.
So she is woman because she came out of
the womb of man. You see the connection
between male and female. So what is her
name? Her name is woman. Isha.
Why is that significant? Because when we
go to Genesis 3, open up Genesis 3,
brother, the entire chapter because I
want to tie it in with the Lord.
Genesis 3, you have the woman there. All
throughout the narrative, she's called
woman. Understand that here you have a
garden where you have a tree
that has forbidden fruit that you're not
supposed to eat of. And this woman was a
virgin. She only had sexual intimacy
with Adam after they were expelled.
Because in Genesis 4:1 we are told Adam
knew Eve his wife and she conceived and
gave birth to a son and she called him
Cain because she said I acquired a man
Yhovah. Now what's interesting the word
man there is the word ish. She didn't
say I acquired a yal a child. The Hebrew
word for child. She goes I acquired a
man and ish.
Interesting. She calls him a man ish.
Because she's I ish who came out of man.
came out of an ish. Now with that said,
I want you to understand
a woman who's a virgin eats forbidden
fruit from a forbidden tree, giving
birth to death. So death enter the world
through a virgin by eating forbidden
fruit hanging on a forbidden tree.
Catching it? Are you catching the first
point? A woman
who is a virgin
brings forth death by eating forbidden
fruit from a forbidden tree. A virgin
woman in a garden eating forbidden fruit
from a forbidden tree giving birth to
death. That's the first connection.
Second connection. This woman was
fashioned and birthed when the first man
was put in a deep sleep and had his side
cut open. Let me show you what sleep
refers to. Sleep becomes a metaphor for
death. How do I know? Go to John 11 and
14.
Now watch where I'm going to go with
this guys. You got to pay attention. You
asked me. This is a deep subject.
>> All right. John 11 starting from verse
11.
This he said and after that he said to
them, "Our friend Lazarus has fallen
asleep, but I go so that I may awaken
him out of sleep."
>> Keep going. The disciples then said to
him, "Lord, if he has fallen asleep, he
will recover." Now Jesus has spoken of
his death, but they thought that he was
speaking of literal sleep.
>> So now notice what Jesus said. Our
friend Lazarus has fallen asleep. Now
they thought he was talking about
literal physical sleep. In reality, he
was saying Lazarus died. So do you see
sleep is often a metaphor for physical
death? Why are the dead called sleeping?
Why are they said to sleep? Because when
someone sleeps, you expect them to
awaken. So those who died in Christ will
awaken physically at the resurrection.
So they don't remain dead because their
death is temporary like sleep is
temporary. And they will awaken in their
physical bodies like you awaken in your
physical body. What an apt metaphor.
Glory to Jesus Christ. Now keep reading.
>> Okay.
>> All the way to 14. Did you read the 14?
Keep reading.
>> Uh verse 14. So Jesus then said to them
plainly, "Lazarus is dead."
>> So plainly, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Because they didn't get it. Our friend
Lazarus is asleep. Okay. If he's asleep,
then why are we going to wake him up?
>> No. Come on, man. That's how I feel
sometimes when I'm live streaming. Some
of my precious brothers and sisters in
Jesus Christ ask me some questions that
blow my mind away. Whenever I'm live
stream with Hussein Meshny or Adam Seik
who is here, that's how they make me
feel. Are you serious? You kidding me? I
gotta explain that too. So even the Lord
Jesus, our God, the perfect God man had
to deal with a bunch of nitwits like
myself, dense people who are not getting
it. A Lord, if he's asleep, then why
bother?
It's one of those, you know, the facial
expression, right? Anyway, so do we see
biblical proof? Sleep is a metaphor for
death.
Notice God put Adam in a deep sleep so
he can cut his side open and he wouldn't
feel pain. Here you have a biblical
basis for anesthesia
because what do people do, doctors do
when they want to cut you open so you
don't feel it? They put you in a deep
sleep. And lo and behold, we already see
that medical fact, that medical
knowledge in Genesis 3,
I'm sorry, Genesis 2. Lord, forgive me
and enable me to recall scriptures
perfectly. Notice God performed surgery
by first putting a man in a deep sleep,
anesthesia, so he wouldn't feel the
pain. Beautiful, the wisdom of God. But
that's not the reason why we're told he
was put in a deep sleep. How did Adam
receive his wife? By put being put in a
deep sleep and having his side cut open.
And from his side being cut open, God
formed the bride of Adam.
Go to John 19.
John 19. Let's read verse 30 to 34.
John chapter 19 starting with verse 30.
Verse 30 says, "Therefore, when Jesus
had received the sore wine, he said, or
the sour wine, I'm sorry." Uh, he said,
"It is finished," and he bowed his head
and gave up his spirit. I love
>> Jesus died, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, keep reading.
>> Verse 31. Then the Jews because it was
the day of prepar uh preparation
so that the bodies would not remain on
the cross uh on the Sabbath for that
Sabbath was a high day. Asked Pilate
that their legs might be broken and that
they might be taken away. So the
soldiers came and broke the legs of the
first man and of the other uh who was
crucified with him. But coming to Jesus,
when they saw that he was already dead,
they did not break his legs.
>> So what did they do?
>> But one of the soldiers pierced his side
with a spear and immediately blood and
water came out.
>> Now this physical thrust with a spear
>> and the physical blood and water coming
out.
Now remember everything in the Bible is
meant to point to greater
spiritualities. Now medically and I got
this from a medical doctor who's
reviewing the gospel's portrayal of
Jesus crucifixion. Blood and water was a
sign that the paricardium the sack in
which the heart is seated had ruptured.
When you have the paricardium the sack
being ruptured excessive amount of fluid
starts developing. So this fluid that
came out was a sign that Jesus's heart
literally ruptured. Jesus literally died
of a broken heart. That's what it tells
us. Don't take my word for it. This is a
medical fact. So here we have an
indication that the paricardium, the
sack in which the heart the heart is
situated had ruptured. His heart had
literally exploded
causing an excessive amount of fluid to
build up. And that fluid came out, blood
and water, meaning his heart ruptured,
exploded. Jesus literally died of a
broken heart. This is what it means
physically. But John is telling us this
because there is a spiritual
significance in blood and water coming
out of Jesus. Blood and water came out
of Jesus because it's the blood of Jesus
that cleanses you of sin. And it's the
water that he gives you that grants you
eternal life. the water of life. So the
two elements that you need to live,
blood for your sins to be cleansed and
water, the water of life, which
symbolizes spirit, are given to us
because of the death of Christ. In other
words, it's Jesus's death that brings
about the forgiveness of sin and
spiritual regeneration, the two
necessary
things that result in the birth of the
church, which is his bride. No death, no
bride. No death, no forgiveness, no
regeneration. If there's no forgiveness,
no regeneration, there's no church. If
there's no church, there's no bride.
I don't think you got it.
Like the first Adam, the last Adam was
put in a deep sleep and had his side cut
open in order to bring about the
formation of his bride, the church.
>> And it's it's amazing. It's amazing,
brother. You're saying
>> if I if I may just make this comment and
you can you can correct me if you think
there's something wrong here but but you
know uh Eve Howa of course we call in
Arabic when she came out of the side of
Adam she also produced you know uh
fruitful and multiplied but in the Lord
it's a spiritual growth and
multiplication.
>> Hallelujah. Exactly. Exactly. That's but
you count it now. The first Adam the
last Adam. The first Adam put in deep
sleep, metaphor for death. And from his
side being cut open, God fashioned his
bride. The last Adam died, was put in
the deep sleep. Notice he died, then his
side was cut open. Notice Adam was put
to sleep, then his side was cut open.
And from Jesus's side being pierced, the
two necessary elements to form
to the church, the formation of the
church as his bride, blood to cleanse
you of your sins, and water symbolizing
the water of life, the Holy Spirit came
out.